I got very lucky I grew up in a
situation where I was losing from day
one I hate things like nice guys finish
last where it's just not true
there's only offense and defense there's
only the force in the dark side never
ever be at the mercy of something else
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge and is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believed
life and learn seven life-changing
pieces of advice from Gary Vee enjoy
okay let's kick it off with advice
number one have a thick skin I got very
lucky I grew up in a situation where I
was losing from day one we were humble
immigrants I got picked on for not
speaking English I wasn't a good student
I wasn't then excelling athlete which
allowed me to create an enormous amount
of thick skin to doing things and not
being scared of judgment because I was
being judged from the beginner do you
does not be noxious Lea thick my skin is
when it comes to business my gift
what anybody says about me or thinks of
me or thinks what I'm doing I'm willing
to go work picking up garbage right now
right now it just doesn't seem so crazy
to me
people get fancy I'm still doing this
that got me here even though people
think I got somewhere you may think I
got somewhere I don't think I'm
somewhere I'm still in the same process
advice number two be dangerous in
everything never ever be at the mercy of
something else so I am the best at my
craft I don't want to be at mercy of my
own employees it's why I got my hands in
absolutely everything
what if they quit what if they get sick
what they get bored what if they win the
lottery
that's literally how I think about
everything that's why I'm in everything
I don't think we're managed but I'm
dangerous enough and everything because
I don't want a point of failure your
point of failure is called Google they
literally change hurt no matter how
evergreen and white hat you've been they
just might decide that video content is
part of their macro strategy so what
what I always think is when you got
something working always have a nest egg
of 20% of your money and energy of
building up other things that if god
forbid your ad goes to zero you're on
the course of being open advice number
three surround yourself with positivity
I believe one of the great ways to mix
things up is what you listen to and who
you surround yourself with I would I'm
unbelievably passionate about people
finding more optimistic practical
friends and I and I think optimism gets
can get can slide into delusion which is
why I say optimistic go practical
there's only offense and defense there's
only the force in the dark side right
and I think that um right now people are
a lot of people are choosing to be
driven by fear and negativity without
realizing it and so if you're listening
right now my biggest thing is start
leaning into
more optimism and positivity also if you
want to have more self-love confidence
and motivation check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join in the
description below we are strong ish
we're really strong we're just being
sold that we're not because there's a
lot of money in a success world please
understand that success is happiness not
net dollars in my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos has been my
biggest asset as an entrepreneur like I
would never take a note like that scares
the piss out of me what these three
people are doing right now advice number
four play outside the rules
I hate things like nice guys finish last
where it's just not true
nice guys might be losing at halftime
but they win the game
nice guys always win it's just so crazy
all this fodder in the system that isn't
true all the faking it to you make it as
a fashion brand that's a great or at
what every single twenty three-year-old
male in the world is doing which is
fronting on Instagram because boys want
girls you know and so like I'm just
unbelievably passionate in trying to
what I realized about myself was oh the
reason I won and I'm good is I've never
played in the vortex I've never played
in the actual rules of life I was an F
student when every immigrant was
supposed to be an A student because
education was the way out I launched an
e-commerce wine business in 1996 right
like that wasn't we have a sneaker
thanks for wearing them
like I've always done things that don't
make sense
I play outside of the actual game and
that has been where all my happiness has
come from and so many things have become
obvious to me by playing outside of the
rules playing outside of the rules is
the best and that's where I want people
to understand we are pandering to so
many things that just aren't true advice
number five give value for free right
now I love this idea I'm gonna give you
a tremendous piece of advice that to
many people that are ideological and
don't actually play in the game push
against but I believe in it the most
you should go sharpen knives for five
restaurants for free for free okay yep
like what like I spoke for free for the
first 13 for no actually I paid for the
first one good that's how it also for
mmm 13 of the first 15 times I ever
spoke I spoke for free including paying
for my flights it's one thing to do free
work it's another thing to do free work
with heavy strategy when I do free work
I try to think of two things how much
exposure is it like Tyler will tell you
sitting right here one of the only times
I still do free work is if it's massive
exposure there are forty nine thousand
people in the audience among and still a
lot of explosions you know like like
it's live on you know it's throwing the
soup I get like I'll pay somebody to put
me in a Superbowl commercial right like
when they when I get exposure or and
that's where I'm at now in the for you
when you pick these five restaurants let
it be the biggest restaurants in your
thirty mile radius
let it be the kindest let it be somebody
who has the biggest Instagram following
and maybe like whether you know you
never want to give with expectation but
it's it's okay to ask you're like hey
I'd love to sharpen your knives for free
and then like you get in there and the
vibes are feeling good maybe like hey
listen like I hope you enjoyed it like
wouldn't mind to take a picture for my
Instagram which then makes them say oh
we'll put you on our Instagram like you
can be thoughtful and do it the right
way but if nothing else if you do it for
free for five people you've established
that you do it word of mouth
a remarkably fascinating thing strategic
free work is one of the great moves in
our society advice number six be people
centric people always like I can't get
my cashiers to like work because they're
only twelve bucks now I'm like no it's
cuz you've never said hello to them face
right so like I'm very people centric I
think there's enormous ROI either in the
short term or the long term some of the
people that work for me I risk may go on
to win an Academy Award as a filmmaker
right like I'd much rather have her like
me than not like me you know everybody's
playing short term
I don't live as if it tomorrow I'm gonna
die and I'm stunned by how many people
do it's all short term ROI every
decision is short term ROI and I think
that's a huge decision so internally I
spend a lot of time and money my HR
department two big my time that I spend
with employees too much this is what I
hear from all my business associates
who then spend all their time asking me
how I do it your employees for me it's
my employees first then the customer
then I can even begin to think about
what the folks in it for me and I've
just watched ninety-five percent of the
business and I interact with start with
them then the customer then they're in
place I think that most of the people
are broken and I think if you have if
you are if you're honest no [ __ ]
right if it just went through your mind
like I am me then customer than my
employees you will lose and I can tell
you that's the majority of businesses
and advice number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip is be
practical how many hands work somewhere
but want to do their own thing raise
your hands
more than half this audience meanwhile
let me tell you why most of the hands
that just went up will never get there
they buy dumb do you know how many
people here literally drive cars to
impress people that they hate people
literally going in debt or getting
further from leaving the job they don't
like to do something I'll make them
happy because they have to buy a certain
car that has a logo that impresses
people that they despise do you
understand up up that is do you know
many people here live in homes where
they don't use more than half the rooms
in the house like we are so
fundamentally in a vortex that makes no
sense that I am unbelievably passionate
understanding how much money you make
and what you can do to get off of it but
the problem is again people are doing so
many things to keep up with the Joneses
to make it look like they're successful
to appease their parents and a million
other things that have nothing to do
with themselves and we need to change
that game do you understand how crazy it
is that if you went to the clearance
aisles of your five biggest retailers in
Australia bought things on clearance
when home relisted it and posted on eBay
that the far majority of this audience
could make between 50 to $100,000 a year
just on doing that for 9 to 10 hours a
day meanwhile everybody's sitting here
with the next big app that's gonna be
the next uber for lawn mowers
the thing that has made me successful
far more than my passion or my energy is
my disproportionate practicality most
people want to look the part of an
entrepreneur that came up with the next
supreme or Adi dis brand or the next
uber or face book yet our $40,000 in
debt work in a job that they hate and
literally if they went to the five
discount stores that dominate this
market buy things on clearance go home
take a picture with their phone and
upload to eBay and then when people buy
it go to the post office and ship it
they would be able to get out of debt
and get into a financial place if people
don't want to do that
because they don't want to be judged for
that being there hustle most people in
this room and this world would rather
lose looking like they're doing
something successful than win and be
judged for doing something that seems
dorky now got a special bonus tip from
Gary on how to understand time that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go
question otherone where do you need to
have a thicker skin number two how can
you surround yourself with more
positivity and number three what value
can you give away for free this and if
you made it this far in the video and
you promise you commit to take action
after watching it give me a hash tag
believe down in the comments as well I
want to celebrate you my friends this is
a remarkably special time and I'm
completely convinced the far majority
and I mean 99% of this room is going to
regret it I'm completely convinced about
it it's not fun for me to say that but
it's very obvious to me that humans take
for granted and are really bad at
perspective and timing the reason i
pushed patience how many people here are
under 30 raise your hands
stand up if you're under 30 don't be a
stand up
let's first of all clap it up for all
the youngsters in the room keep standing
you're young you're not tired yet if
you're standing right now you really
have like let's get into perspectives
and actual understanding if you're
standing right now with the way that
modern medicine is actually evolving
there is a very high percentage that
you're gonna live three more lives that
you've already lived if not five like do
you understand why I struggle when
people give up on a year or two in or
upset that they haven't gotten there yet
three years in when you phases are about
to live four more lives I'm being
serious
like you're literally gonna live four
more lives five more like from the day
you were born that you cannot remember -
right this second you're about to do
that three to four more times
you can sit literally literally your
biggest advantage is timing for all the
great things that I have in my life I
would literally give it up all of it all
of it just to be 25 I would give up for
17 years I'd give up everything I have
because that's how valuable time is and
the far majority of this room has time
time as their asset and every day the
number one asset they have time they
give away by being impatient mainly on
the back of listening to society or
their parents that they have to have
their figured out at this age the fact
that people actually think at 18 22 or
30 you have to have your figured out is
ridiculous let me promise you all those
parents and uncles and grandparents that
push down your throat that you have to
figure it out by now they still haven't
figured at the
I mean it so this nonsense this nonsense
that you have to have it figured out at
eighteen twenty to thirty you know many
people freaked the [ __ ] out at thirty
how many feeler thirty right now that
was crazy right
like people lose their at thirty like
meanwhile their kid
and so I'm unbelievably aware lately
that one of the you know people are just
like why do you when I talk about my
parents and not coming from anything but
the more that I live I'm like no reason
I really win is cuz I understand time
and listen I know I can get hit by a bus
or get terminally ill I get it here's
the problem that's far more unlikely for
the majority of us the math works in
your favor and we are stunningly not
patient patience has been the foundation
of my sick patients adversity these are
the foundations of my success Evan thank
you so much for having a couple of
seconds and being able to tell the
believe nation a little bit about
empathy wines it means a lot to me that
you would take this valuable real estate
and and time on your channel to give me
some love means a lot it's just good
karma points and so you're just you're
awesome thank you believe nation if
you're into wine at all go to empathy
wines calm my whole careers work was
poured into producing a wine that
rivaled forty to sixty dollar wine for
twenty bucks a bottle I'm just super
excited about this subscription-based
wine business
you can order three six or twelve
bottles in subscription form Rose a
white red
if you cook if you search on Instagram
or Twitter you will be blown away
people are literally like I don't even
like Gary B but the lines good super
proud of the effort thanks Evan for the
time wishing you guys all happy and
healthy
if you want to see the ten best pieces
of advice for new entrepreneurs check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there what
would have happened if the fourth one
hadn't worked we would have failed yeah
but let's talk about the one of the the
failures were spectacular